près de 290 1000 québécois
supplémentaires sont désormais inscrits
un groupe de médecins et pourront
bénéficier d'un suivi de la part d'un
professionnel de la santé c'est
davantage que l'objectif qui avait été
fixé par le gouvernement qui était de
250 milles alors avec nous pour en
parler le docteur marc andré amiotte
président et directeur général de la
fédération des médecins omnipraticiens
du québec bonjour bonjour alors d'abord
c'est à dire qu'on n'a plus le québécois
qui ont accès maintenant un médecin de
famille est ce que ça veut dire qu'il
n'y aura plus d'attentes
il ya encore quand même beaucoup de gens
qui sont en attente de médecins camille
mais c'est un premier pas dans la dans
la bonne direction et ce malgré
malgré la pénurie de 1000 médecins au
québec qui malgré le fait que les
médecins de famille travaillent beaucoup
en deuxième ligne dans les salles
d'urgence conseil un bond est
actuellement sur les unités
d'hospitalisation avec l'aco vire dans
leurs chaussettes un effort
supplémentaire de la part des médecins
puis l'objectif c'est quand même
d'atteindre 500 mille passants au 31
mars 2003 donc les efforts se
poursuivent pour inscrire davantage de
patients mais comment on va s'y prendre
pour atteindre la prochaine cible qui
est quand même assez ambitieux et que
vous venez de le dire 500 mille patients
à d'ici 2023 ça va venir assez
rapidement
ben il
ya le guichet d'accès première ligne
c'est un numéro de téléphone où les gens
peuvent appeler et où ils vont être
orientées vers la meilleure ressource
pour répondre à leurs besoins donc ce
sera un élément important c'est à dire
que on ne réserve la consultation
médecin famille que ce qui nécessite le
médecin de famille l'expertisé du
médecin de famille donc on n'y serait
pas arrivé
ça c'est tout cela qui est en cours de
déploiement qui devrait être déployé à
la grandeur du québec que clément
déployés d'ici septembre
2021 le mois prochain alors les patients
qui n'ont pas de médecin de famille ou
qui sont inscrits un groupe de médecins
vont pouvoir appeler à ce numéro et là
ils vont être évalués et orienté par une
infirmière vers la meilleure ressource
donc on ajoute de la pertinence à la
consultation mais tiens on a toujours
dit les médecins craignent qu'on faisait
partie de la solution mais qu'on ne
pouvait plus seuls à assumer l'entièreté
des besoins de la population québécoise
en première mais on a besoin d'un hebdo
professionnels que sont les
physiothérapeutes les pharmaciens les
infirmières les inhalothérapeutes
oui et on voit présentement l'écran est
encore énormément de patients qui sont
en attente qui souhaiteraient bien avoir
un médecin de famille ou même accès à un
médecin de famille mais ce guichet
d'accès ça ne garantit pas un suivi
rapproché avec un médecin saucisses et
des plats rome pour certains patients sa
garantie quand même un suivi avec un
groupe de professionnels donc c'est à
dire que un groupe de médecins
accompagné de deux des infirmières des
physiothérapeutes et des pharmaciens
vers qui les médecins travaillent dans
les groupes de médecine familiale
donc si le médecin découvre un diabète
en le patient qui est ordonnée ou
inscrits collectivement bat ivo yvonne
nécessairement avoir besoin d'un suivi
et se suivent ils peuvent être assurés
par des internes ya clinicienne avec qui
on collabore d'ailleurs les infirmières
avec qui on collabore dans les gms
suivent une partie de notre clientèle de
millas inscrits individuellement
ils sont suivi conjointement par
différents professionnels
et je me permets de vous interrompre sa
fait très rapidement je veux qu'on parle
rapidement justement des admissions en
médecine parce qu'on a besoin de plus de
médecins on a les plus récents chiffres
donc les émissions qui sont passés de
830 en 2019 2020 à 1003 pour les
inscriptions 2023/2024 bien sûr c'est
important d'augmenter les admissions
est-ce que ce sera suffisant pour
répondre à tous cette demande selon vous
l'enjeu c'est encore une fois c'est un
pas dans la bonne direction mais l'enjeu
principal il est le choix des étudiants
la majorité des étudiants choisissent la
spécialité plutôt que la médecine
familiale donc l'an passé bien qu'on a
qu'on ait affaire 55% des points en
médecine familiale il ya plusieurs
postes qui restent à chaque année non
comblés et ça depuis 2013 ces brèves de
470 médecin qui proche de résidence en
médecine familiale qui n'ont pas été
comblées sa c4 ce sont dix médecins qui
nous manque aujourd'hui qui nous manque
pour les 30 prochaines années dont ils
font travailler aussi sur l'attractivité
de la médecine mais il faut que les
étudiants à choisir cette trop valorisé
effectivement la profession docteur marc
andré amiotte vous êtes président
directeur général de la fédération des
médecins omnipraticiens du québec merci
infiniment d'avoir été avec nous après
plusieurs bonnes journées auront pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit